in the aftermath of the election bank
stocks have rallied basically because
people really see it as an opportunity
for them to get some really fun the
regulatory side of things and so we saw
Bank of America reaching its highest
point since May JP Morgan up there as
well while he was campaigning Donald
Trump said that we were gonna see a
temporary moratorium on all financial
regulation that would be a total game
changer for the banks because they've
just kind of seen regulation climbing
for them and the cost of compliance has
gotten really high alternatively Donald
Trump and some of the new members of
Congress have said that they would
really like to do some regulatory reform
around the dodd-frank act so that act
was what Congress passed in an effort to
make it so that banks couldn't be too
big to fail I think going forward for
the banks what we're gonna see is an
effort to maybe garner some bipartisan
support to roll back some of these more
strict regulations that we've seen in
the past couple of years if there's any
way that they can maybe lessen those
restrictions a little bit I think
they'll definitely go for it
you